[Music]
this podcast has bad words
i have a strong belief that it's
disrespectful to get rid of something if
someone else took the time and money to
give it to me how do i let go of this
belief and make decluttering less
emotionally draining
i think you might call this a limiting
belief yeah
and i understand where it's birthed from
right this is also the need for approval
that we've sort of been talking about on
this maximal episode it seems to me that
if i'm afraid of something
because it's going to
upset someone else yeah
hey it's a bit of hubris for me to think
that i have the power to upset you
because only you have the power to upset
you i think all the great spiritual
teachers would would teach us that
but it certainly feels like you can
upset me yeah right it really does yeah
we disempower ourselves
i'll mention that sedona method again
because he he has this
he keeps calling you to the basic
underlying desires to notice what's
happening when you have something like
this happen like oh i notice i i feel
like i believe this or i'm concerned
that
uh if this happens it's gonna and we get
lost in kind of the stories that have
spun out and so it's kind of it's the
method calls you back into kind of deep
deep deep deep down
what's the underlying desire here and
the three basic desires that it keeps
calling up
that all this stuff is built on
according to this book and i it holds
true in my experience as i've been doing
this method
the desire for control
the desire for
approval and the desire for safety or
security
and if you can find and the and there's
nothing problem there's no problem with
having control or having
approval or having safety or security
but when we want them
when we're we're trying to get them we
don't have them yes
when we're looking for approval when
we're seeking approval it's because we
we're actually pushing approval away in
this sort of upside down way and it
uh and it even practically tends to play
out that way like if you are with
somebody if you ever hang out with
somebody and you really feel like
they're trying to get your approval
you're kind of less likely to give it to
them right you're like this person feels
really needy or really like trying to
kiss my ass or whatever
and
uh
if you're just coming from a place of
having approval already you're more
likely to be liked yes yeah if you're
coming from a place where you're worried
about being disrespectful
and how they're gonna feel and you're
trying to get their approval
you're probably more likely to get into
that energy like
don't think of a white elephant don't
think of a white elephant right you're
like
when you're resisting as opposed to like
oh i'm noticing a desire for approval
can i
say yes to that
like not yes to the story of it just to
the sensation of it notice that it's
here and just release that
then just let that go
and then we'll find like you obviously
have uh sorry i forget her name
ellen helen
have a desire to respect people and and
to respect have respect and love and
dignity
and
if you just rest in that and trust
that your decisions will reflect that as
you're kind of inhabiting that space as
opposed to trying to move all the chess
pieces right i need to do this in order
to
uh make people and and that's where our
limiting beliefs their their fruit on
the tree
like is if you can get down into the
branches and into the roots and into the
soil
some of that fruit it really just takes
care of itself yeah
man if i had a pit the answer i would
say something like uh
there are more ways to gain someone's
approval than making yourself miserable
and that's what helen is doing she's
making herself miserable to gain someone
and there's a lot there's so many more
meaningful ways
to show compassion to someone to gain
someone's approval than
to be like look i'm i'm sitting in
misery for you yeah yeah to make
yourself miserable is not a great way to
gain someone else's approval right right
and they're not gonna actually feel
loved for me being miserable no because
they don't want that from you either
right i mean unless they're you're some
sort of weird s m relationship but even
then
there's a there's a non-suffering yeah
no there's a still consent under that
yeah
yes if it's non-consensual it's no fun i
really am trying to find a way to weave
in the dog story that you talk about
through your book
and uh so when i was so there's a
spoiler alert if you're listening to
this like i'm gonna i'm gonna tell this
story i'm gonna do a really bad job of
paraphrasing it but it's about this man
who doesn't want to walk his dog in the
rain
and he starts figuring out the a way to
avoid walking his dog in the rain and
not only that but he moralizes almost
like walking the dog in the rain and
when i was listening to the story where
i thought it was going was
um
hey uh
it's gonna rain in life
and if you think that there's like
if you think that if you think that
there's an entity out there that's gonna
not make it rain you're you're you're
delusional
um
and
that i thought the story was going to
like oh this man is going to accept the
fact that
hey man
it's not about avoiding the [ __ ] it's
about how do you walk through the [ __ ]
you know yeah um but it turns out again
spoilers raining [ __ ] in this moment yes
exactly
so i mean the character in the story it
kind of it might as well be yeah it
might have might as well be so spoiler
alert fast forward 15 seconds if you
don't want to hear the end of this
parable uh throughout this book but he
realizes
that there is no
[ __ ] dog
like he's like wait i don't even have a
dog
and and i think
i think there's something there for
helen like in that story of like you you
think that you think there's some but
there's
really helen like you're making this up
yourself you're making up a problem that
isn't a problem yes yeah
here's the spoiler on this it's like
it's actually on the cover all right and
so the beautiful thing you did with this
with the book which by the way i agree
with ryan the the i just started the
audiobook version last week but i just i
read the actual physical book when it
first came out
and
i will tell you this that the cover it's
it's a well there's a dual cover here um
so you have this real simple cover of a
man who appears to be walking his dog
in the rain but of course when you
open up the cover since you've already
spoiled it he's just walking an empty
leash an empty leash yeah and then of
course there's this
cover you design clearly on mushrooms
oh that's gorgeous man the second cover
oh dude that's great it's like the most
simple cover for this and then also sort
of the most complex and the metaphor is
obviously that we we are both you know
we are we are simple we are complex
we tend to make things way more complex
but also there is a simplicity within
the complexity did you enjoy this
standalone patreon highlight if so you
can listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100 percent
advertisement free